[Música]
la persona que sabiendo leer no lee no
tiene ninguna ventaja sobre aquel que
nunca aprendió a leer mark twain
hace 45 años mis padres me enviaron a la
escuela y de las primeras cosas que me
enseñaron fue a leer me acuerdo que la
profesora esmeradamente empezó con las
vocales cuando ya las habíamos todas
empezó una una con las consonantes nos
enseñó a combinarlas para cuando se
acabó el alfabeto se supone que ya
sabíamos combinar vocales y consonantes
ya sabíamos leer era lo obvio
transcurrió la primaria y la mayoría de
los conocimientos que adquiríamos los
transmitía el profesor en el aula de
clase nosotros teníamos que leer si
acaso los apuntes que habíamos hecho de
la pizarra o del mismo dictado de la
profesora
en el bachillerato las cosas cambiaron
ahora los profesores nos daban por ahí
un 80 por ciento de la información en el
clase el resto y había que gestionarlo
con investigación había que leer un
poquito más pero les confieso que a eso
yo también le hacía trampa yo leía poco
mis resultados académicos en primaria y
bachillerato no fueron muy brillantes de
hecho fueron más bien bajos pasaba con
los mínimos necesarios
pero cuando llegué a la universidad
quise limpiar mi baja autoestima y quise
ser un buen estudiante y empecé a hacer
a poner todo de mí para lograrlo dije
joyería ser pon atención en clase y
empecé a poner mucho cuidado en la clase
pero pasó algo curioso ahora los
profesores si acaso le daba a uno a uno
el 40% de la información el 60 restante
habría que investigarlo había que
gestionarlo con lectura y rápido quedó
clarita mi debilidad como lector yo no
leía muy bien yo me cansaba rápido me
daba sueño
no comprendía y tenía que realizar el
texto varias veces para entenderlo
como mi propósito de ser buen estudiante
estaba firme
yo quería casa acudir me desarrolla de
mal estudiante decidí poner fuerza de
voluntad y empecé a dejar de dormir
tanto y empezar a ver más pero el
esfuerzo pronto empezó a marcarse me en
mi cuerpo empecé a verme flaco ojeroso
cansado y sin ilusiones un amigo me
percibió así y me dijo jorge díaz ser tú
estás enfermo te estás alimentando bien
tuve que contarle mis peripecias para
poder rendir académicamente y mi amigo
me dijo algo que nunca he olvidado jorge
eliécer la humanidad está haciendo una
transición obligada
salimos de la era industrial y nos
estamos metiendo a la era del
conocimiento a la era de la información
y la tecnología jorge eliécer hazte un
curso de lectura rápida eso es lo
pertinente hoy día si quieres ser
protagonista y no meramente un
espectador
algún día buscando alternativas encontré
una institución que ofrecía ayuda en
estos casos lo primero que me ofrecieron
fue un diagnóstico de mi lectura me
pidieron leer un texto mientras ellos
cronometraban el tiempo cuando ya
terminé me presentaron un test de
preguntas para verificar mi comprensión
lectora cuando lo entregué me dijeron
tuvo algún problema con las preguntas
les dije no no con las preguntas no tuve
problemas fue con las respuestas
bien el caso es que pasado eso me dieron
el resultado
no pudo haber sido más desalentador yo
leía 165 palabras por minuto era muy
bajo yo leía de forma silábica y
recuerden yo ya estaba en la universidad
hacía regresiones en el texto por
inseguridad vocalizaba todo lo que leía
aun cuando leyera solo para mí mismo y
la contención lectora muy baja
palabras más palabras menos me dijeron
que yo no sabía leer
pues tal vez me puse pálido tal vez me
puse muy triste y ellos lo advirtieron
porque enseguida me quiero jorge eliécer
no se preocupe le preocupe esto le pasa
a todo el mundo todos los que vienen
aquí les va igual es que el problema no
es si usted es inteligente o si no es
inteligente el problema es que cuando
usted estaba pequeño a usted le
enseñaron mal
ah caramba eso despertó mi interés y les
pregunté cómo así ustedes porque saben
eso entonces me contestaron que fue lo
primero que usted le enseñaron cuando
fue a la escuela a aprender a leer yo
tenía una sola respuesta y ya se las
conté a ustedes las vocales las
consonantes se da cuenta jorge eliécer a
usted lo enseñaron a ver letras haber
símbolos no a leer son dos cosas muy
distintas
caramba yo me desconsuelo mucho con eso
el recuerdo que llegue a la casa y le
dije a mi mamá
se acuerda cuando me mandó a la escuela
a aprender a leer sí claro mi hijo que
paso que hoy descubrí que parece que esa
plática se perdió
no aprendí
tengo que volver a aprender bien el caso
es que el día del diagnóstico yo hice
una pregunta
hoy día puedo dar testimonio que lo que
decía albert eistein era cierto son más
importantes las preguntas que las
respuestas yo les pregunté que podía
hacer para que mis hijos no aprendieran
mal
si a mí ya me estaba tocando leer mucho
que les iba a tocar a mis hijos
no hubo respuesta
salir de allí y empecé a buscar
soluciones empecé a buscar libros que
hablaran de técnicas de estudio de
técnicas de lectura y note que todos se
referían a lo mismo
tenía que reeducar mis ojos para que no
vieran letras sino palabras o frases
completas en un solo golpe de vista así
reducían los movimientos académicos que
eran los que producían el cansancio el
sueño la pereza tenía que aprender a
leer sin vocalizar porque eso relanza
también la lectura tenía que leer
comprendiendo lo que estaba escrito no
leyendo códigos grafológicos
para cuándo
mis hijos
nacieron ya tenía una inquietud bien
construida no vamos a dejar que aprendan
como nos enseñaron a nosotros porque el
mundo está muy exigente en lectura
bien
valeria empezó a ser enseñada en la casa
a los 18 meses porque nosotros íbamos a
preguntarle a los jardines cómo es que
les enseñan a leer a los niños y nos
pasó algo curioso siempre decían no
porque usted no se preocupe a que tengo
profesoras expertas licenciadas de las
mejores universidades
prekinder su hija va a ver las vocales y
si alcanzamos las consonantes mps y b
y yo decía caramba otra vez lo mismo
como si el mundo no hubiera cambiado
como cuando me enseñaron a mí
pero yo me dediqué a la investigación y
descubrió una cosa curiosa que se las
quiero contar esos métodos que hoy se
están utilizando en no todos pero en la
mayoría de los colegios tienen 350 años
de historia y no cambian
como si el mundo no hubiera cambiado
ahora entenderán por qué los índices de
lecturas son tan bajos
habíamos leído unos libros del doctor
glenn doman que aseguraba que los bebés
no solo podían sino que además ellos
querían aprender a leer
y atacamos con valeria cuando tenía 18
meses como lo hicimos empezamos a buscar
vocabulario de este que rodea a los
niños y empezamos a hacer tarjetas y en
ellas escribíamos palabras
palabras completas porque la
neurociencia nos había enseñado que el
cerebro no procesa información abstracta
y las letras son abstractas es difícil
que el cerebro las procese estoy
buscamos me sacas a mamá papá bebé casa
feliz y con estas era que le enseñábamos
a los niños
repetíamos varias veces las palabras
durante la semana
pero a veces la actividad se tornaba
monótona obviamente pero eso fue útil
porque nos ayudó a ponernos creativos
y empezamos a idear formas de jugar con
los niños
allí está valeria nicolás y mi sobrino
favorito
santiago fíjense cuando venían de visita
que jugaban con las palabras
quiero que observen la cara de nicolás
porque el reto era quien encuentra la
palabra tal y miren lo que hacía nicolás
cuando le encontraba
es como cuando colombia hace gol
y no puedo aceptar hoy que me digan que
leer no es divertido para los niños
porque si lo es la lectura es un juego
maravilloso
tuvimos que dejarnos jugar a las
escondidas nosotros íbamos al cuarto de
baleària y poníamos las tarjetas en
diferentes partes y le decíamos valeria
ve a tu cuarto y busca la palabra casa y
valeria regresaba el rato con la palabra
casa
y eran pequeños
después de ver muchas palabras tuvimos
que hacer un avance hacia las frases
pero allí hubo una idea poderosa que nos
ayudó enormemente yo había tenido que
lidiar con una baja autoestima que
heredé de una crianza complicada en un
ambiente hostil emocionalmente y había
conocido la programación
neurolingüística la estaba usando ya mí
se me ocurrió porque usar frases como la
mula sube la loma el oso lamela los a la
mula me la mima a su mini na
esas son las de la cartilla no decidimos
utilizar otras cosas
frases positivas yo puedo soy campeón te
amo estoy feliz
muchas gracias te quiero tengo éxito
hablo claro
aprendo rápido soy libre y la repetición
así que los niños las interioricen y con
ellas construyan la bases de su psiquis
que más adelante es la tarjeta de
crédito con la que negocian las
oportunidades de la vida
cuando valeria tenía dos años y medio
fue al jardín por primera vez con una
pequeña novedad ya sabía leer recuerdo
que una profesora me dijo alguna vez don
jorge yo llamo a mis compañeros y le
pido a valeria que lea y ponen una cara
porque es que valeria leía divino
recuerdo que una vez otra profesora me
dijo correría serio tengo que poner las
hojas de guía en cada puesto de mis
estudiantes y tengo que ir por cada
puesto explicándoles lo que tienen que
hacer y cuando llegó donde nicolás
nicolás ya está trabajando y yo me
acerco dijo pero tú qué haces nicolás y
nicolás me señala y dice como ahí dice
él ya había leído las instrucciones y
estaba trabajando la lectura siempre fue
un plus para mis hijos siempre fue una
ventaja extraordinaria hoy les cuento el
proceso académico de ellos ha sido
gratificante ha sido muy bonito
con el tiempo
nos dimos cuenta de lo beneficioso que
fue enseñarles diferente y a tiempo ahí
está mi hija ayudándole al primero a
aprender a leer porque esas eran las
formas como ellos jugaban y se divertían
mis hijos entraron a la universidad más
exigente del país y pasaron en el primer
intento y hoy son estudiantes
concluyentes de dos carreras exigentes
medicina ingeniería de sistemas y debo
darles un testimonio porque a eso viene
la lectura es la madre del rendimiento
académico la mejor campaña en favor de
la lectura es enseñar a leer bien porque
como decía albert eistein no podemos
exigir resultados distintos y seguir
haciendo lo mismo
hace 17 años decidí que me inició a
nivel estar consagrada a contarle al
mundo que la educación es patrimonio de
todos y a todos nos corresponde
mejorarla y dentro de la educación la
lectura es la principal y sima
herramienta a ti te voy a hacer una
invitación lemas no te quejes de que la
pobreza lemas no te quejes de que el
cambio es terrible más
les voy a recomendar un libro un libro
que a mí me cambió la vida lo descubrí
cuando empecé en la universidad
ese libro es fácil de leer es fácil de
entender
estoy seguro que ustedes también les va
a cambiar la vida el libro si quieren
anótenlo por favor el libro que tienen
que leer ese libro que ustedes quieran
no el que les imponen hoy día y
diversidad de temas para leer lean lo
que quieran pero lean
hay un estudio científico económico
social que dice que los países más
pobres como consecuencia no leen
pero hay otra postura sobre el mismo
punto muy interesante y es que dice que
los países que no leen terminan siendo
pobres creo que les acabo de dar la
fórmula si queremos salir de la pobreza
tenemos que leer
de esas cuatro horas que la gente está
desperdiciando en internet 45 minutos
serían suficientes para leer un libro a
la semana 52 al año y al año su vida
nunca volverá a ser la misma muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]